welcome to all of you for the second
time today we had a fascinating
discussion I thought this morning with
the group of students from NUS this was
this is great where I could get used to
that kind of style of doing teaching and
engagement across the time zones it was
great it's great so we have a full plate
of to offer you today including guest
who is with us Tony Hall and so I will
make my comments very very brief and
then a dog is going to follow after me
and after that Tony Hall and then Tony
Blair is going to complete the circle so
you know what I wanted just to briefly
briefly mention and highlight it seems
to me at least also from our reading
throughout the course but this in
particular also for today's session it
seems to me that both faith tradition
and the advocates of economic
globalization they have interest there's
interest in improving the lot of the of
the poor right both the market economy
its version of economic globalization
contains a promise to lift people out of
poverty poverty but also it kind of has
a history of betrayal of the of the poor
right history of either in the process
of marching onward leaving people
dislocated unsure about their their
destinies and so forth or even if we
won't looked at the large map of the
world leaving certain even whole
continents untouched at least as of yet
one might say I think that's also true
of the faith traditions on the one hand
just about all the faith traditions
emphasize concern for the poor for the
needy that's at the heart of many many
of the fades not necessarily the thing
at the heart but one of the most
important things that fates are
concerned with and yet as we've read
also in our reading for today especially
kind of critique from the liberation
theologian side of things there's also a
long history of betrayal of that mission
the port and siding with those who are
powerful in kind of unconcerned with
what's going on on the ground where
people in fact suffer and I think maybe
it will be good for us to think in terms
of both in the lives of both its promise
and also a failure and betrayal to think
maybe that for both faith and
globalization it might be good to think
that the effects of both of these two on
the poor and on the weak are one of the
criteria important criteria how we judge
both fades and globalization processes
and I think the background for that
might be a background presupposition
might be that and maybe that's
controversial but that's how I would put
it that a humanity of a system or
humanity of a society is measured by how
it treats it weakest members and if
that's the case that provides us quite
an important a criterion is maybe too
strong and too kind of clearly
formulated but at least the guideline in
terms of how to assess the performance
quote-unquote of those faith traditions
and and economic side of globalization
processes second comment that I want to
make concerns the notion of what it
means to be poor and what it means to be
wealthy that's I think among many other
things that faith traditions contribute
to this whole debate is one of these
things you can put it differently also
you can ask the question now you'll
smile a laugh because you've heard me
ask that question many times what's the
wealth for right I ask the question
what's the whole economic system for but
also what is wealth for put differently
how it fits into the larger account of
what it means to lead one lives once
live well and especially if we
distinguish between safely say that
human flourishing consists of has to
formal components as i said before life
going well for one
and life being led well now we can all
agree that it's hard to argue that life
going well for one that life is going
well for one if they live on one dollar
a day right or even less in many many
cases no access to health and so forth
so the concern for reaching a certain
threshold of of wealth so as to be able
to be nourished to be able to have a per
tunity to thrive all of us would agree
on this in terms of constituting kind of
poetic and a bottom-line absolute almost
poverty but I think it's very important
for for a religious folks from religious
perspective to think about what
constitutes then wealth and what
constitutes poverty above that threshold
and I think one can distinguish in most
of the traditions something like what I
might call the two types of people right
one type of person is not enough person
no matter what you've got and how you
how you fare you're just not enough it's
always needs to be more right and always
more than enough person right now always
more than enough person is really a
funny thing to to to invoke in the in
today right it seems counter to many of
the basic intuitions we have about how
the whole world and wealth creation is
being run but in just about all
religious traditions there is something
like that of more than enough kind of a
person I think that goes that's behind
some of the detachment ideas in Buddhism
in Hinduism that's certainly behind the
idea of contentment whether that's a
stoic version of contentment or that
that's a Christian version of other
religious versions of contentment and it
seemed to me that something of that sort
needs to be there for people actually to
be willing to engage in care for the
poor if you are simply concerned about
yourself and if you see yourself as not
enough person what will take you outside
of yourself in order to reach out
whether that's reaching out in giving
others whether that's reaching out in
creating conditions where they could
thrive whatever
that might be I think poverty
alleviation presume presumes people who
are well just about just slightly more
than enough people at least right Co
able to be able to give engage with a
question and problem of poverty whether
that's a large structural level or very
small personal level I think that's all
that I want to want to say and I'll pass
it on now to Doug